So what does this have to do with approximation algorithms?
Well, it shows that even though a problem can be very hard initially,
once you know just small parts of the solution
it can become rather easy to obtain a complete solution.
So the deep resolve that underlies the statement here
basically works the same way.
It says that if you know a small part
of the solution of Clique and Independent Set,
then you can use this to construct an optimal solution.
The real proof of this is much more complex,
but that is the basic idea.
Having a constant factor approximation algorithm for Clique or Independent Set
would reveal so much information about a perfect solution
that you could construct a polynomial time algorithm from this.
And actually there's a similar result for Vertex Cover,
surprisingly, but Alice doesn't need to worry that much,
so for Vertex Cover
there is not constant factor approximation
that is better than 1.36,
unless P=NP.
And actually, many people believe that this number here should be higher,
but this is the highest number that has been proven so far.